Did you just, uh, look at my boobs?
I was not my intention. I didn't uh..
You're looking at them right now
Now I did because you were talking about 'em.
Testing. Oh. Failed. Oh my god.
Cool. Alright.
You just looked at them again.
I wasn't...
You never forget the one who steals your heart,
or the one who kicks your ass
(screaming)
Some fishy shit is happening on our beach
and my balls say we need to go over there and check it out.
It's a bad idea Mitch, we're lifeguards.
My balls say, "Let's just take it easy right here".
Well my balls are saying fuck that noise.
Let's go handle business. Your balls are bullies.
Baywatch works because we follow rules.
LET'S DO SOME SHOTS!
This guy is a trainwreck.
I'm Matt Brody.
And not a single fuck was given.
He's one of the best swimmers in the whole world
It's like if a human fucked a jetski
which is impossible but it would be so cool
There's your cot. Don't jack off on my sheets.
Just remember I'm always watching.
What the fuck?!
Leon, teach him some manners.
Have fun boys.
You going night night bitch.
Who's your daddy now?
All things considered, things could have gone a lot worse
Hey! A foot! That's good luck, pick it up.
We need to search the morgue for evidence.
Check his taint for needle marks
You want me to check his taint?
Lift his fucking scrotum and check his taint
Dude it's a taint man. It's a taint.
You didn't even look, get closer.
Oh smells like yoghurt, oh there's a hole. That's just his butt hole.
Smile
I'm posting that
Do not post that
Just a handful of ball sack
You turned the canals into the goddamn X games.
Yeah, that's 'cause we were in lifeguard pursuit
Oh okay
My bad.
Except for there's no fucking such thing as lifeguard pursuit